we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i have for
you today true genuine racism and
xenophobia we often have to dance around
these words and we hear from the right
that the worst thing you can do is to
say that somebody is racist but this is
just true genuine racism and xenophobia
this is troy York I can't tell if he is
disguising his voice into one of his
many characters or if this is just the
genuine Troy York character as far as we
know Troy York isn't even the actual
genuine character we just believed that
that's the genuine character and here he
is criticizing me for not using the
right term when referring to African
immigrants take a listen one you keep
referring to immigrants who would come
from sub-saharan Africa to Europe and
not refer to them instead as invaders
and take me
why should Europe take pieces people and
that's a pretty good idea
you don't even put a long hold Sahara
Desert but you need to prevent these
pretty much of human illiterate people
from companies reporting and
overwhelming but you like to follow the
room a name partner this is this is
racism right I mean this is this is what
it is saying we should build a wall to
prevent subhuman illiterate invaders
from coming from Africa to Europe do we
need more of an analysis like I don't
even know that there's that much more to
say this is just that's what it isn't
and this exists okay so everybody always
wants to add caveats and say well the
you have to understand the kind saying
that anybody from South South
sub-saharan Africa who wants to go to
Europe is a subhuman illiterate invader
that's sort of that that's racist unless
he's not being serious here in which we
have no reason to believe playing this
ongoing joke but why does what is what
he gets so much pleasure out of that it
calling all the time and making racist
comments extraordinarily bizarre
yeah so that's what it is it's it's just
genuine racism folks there's nothing
else we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about a plane
turned around because of a very very
bizarrely behaving woman on a flight and
much much more including someone who is
punishing man spreaders with bleach in a
viral video these stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up become a
member become a patron get instant
access and we'll speak to you that